gusty winds and extreme droughts are  fueling wildfires in the West flames are  burning across seven states this morning  the National Weather Service issued red  flag warnings for parts of Arizona  Colorado Nevada Utah and Wyoming in  Colorado more than 3000 homes are  evacuated this morning the largest and  most threatening fire has burned more  than 27 thousand acres in the San Juan  National Forest that's north of Durango  a wildfire in Wyoming's Medicine Bow  National Forest west of Cheyenne doubled  in size in just over 24 hours that  forcing out nearly 400 families out of  their homes and in Utah a fast-moving  brush fire destroyed eight homes in Moab  yesterday